This visualization has made it clear that maybe the number of
emails from a person of interest to a given person is not that helpful, or
the number of emails that a person sends to persons of interest.
But now I'm using my human intuition to say maybe what I want is to effectively
scale this feature by the total number of messages to or from this person.
And this is something that I'm going to ask you to do in a coding quiz.
So I'll give you the Enron data set and
I'll point you towards the features that are relevant.
I'll give you these two features as well as the total number of messages to and
from a person, and I want you to return two new features.
So what I'll give you is these two features that you just made and
also the total number of messages from and to each person in the data set.
And what I want you to do is to do the division so
that you get a scaled variable of sorts in return.
The fraction of messages to this person that come from persons of interest and
from this person to persons of interest.